103m  from the home of mentally insane  adolescence  she is described as an Asian female  brown hair brown eyes and she is  considered dangerous  copy lucky me  [Music]  or learning this big bad world  dude you okay you don't sound like  you're from around here I mean  [Music]  you live in New Orleans  I'm not going back there  stop  we'll touch it like run away from  somewhere I don't wanna go back  [Applause]  she's got no place to stay I'm helping  her out for a little while since when do  you help people hey  she's a little miracle  she's a fugitive don't put it  if you see this girl do not look in her  eyes  why do you think you're in charge  I knew something freaky was gonna happen  tonight but it's a full moon I like feel  it in my ovaries I swear to God  [Music]